"THE FAULKNER FOCUS" UP NEXT.
>> Harris: STAGGERING NEW
NUMBERS ON THE BORDER CRISIS AS
THE WHITE HOUSE NOW ADMITS ITS
OWN POLICIES MAY BE DRIVING THE
MIGRANT SURGE.
I’M HARRIS FAULKNER.
YOU’RE IN "THE FAULKNER FOCUS"
AND WE’RE WATCHING THE DIRE
SITUATION OF CHILD MIGRANTS
STREAMING ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THE BIDEN TEAM IS DESPERATE TO
FIND PLACES TO HOUSE THEM.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT UNUSED
SCHOOL BUILDINGS, MILITARY
BASES AND A NASA FACILITY.
THE WHITE HOUSE SOUTHERN BORDER
COORDINATOR IS NOT DENYING THAT
BIDEN’S POLICIES PLAY A ROLE IN
THE SURGE AND ARE ENCOURAGING
SMUGGLERS TO BE BOLDER THAN
EVER.
>> WE’VE SEEN SURGES BEFORE.
SURGES THE END TO RESPOND TO
HOPE AND THERE WAS A
SIGNIFICANT HOPE FOR A MORE
HUMANE POLICY AFTER FOUR YEARS
OF PENT UP DEMAND.
SO I DON’T KNOW WHETHER I WOULD
CALL THAT A COINCIDENCE BUT I
CERTAINLY THINK THAT THE IDEA
THAT A MORE HUMANE POLICY WOULD
BE IN PLACE MAY HAVE DRIVEN
PEOPLE TO MAKE THAT DECISION.
>> Harris: WELL, HERE IS HOW
MANY ARE COMING.
MORE THAN 100,000 MIGRANTS WERE
ENCOUNTERED AT THE BORDER IN
FEBRUARY.
THAT’S A 97% JUMP FROM THE SAME
MONTH OF LAST YEAR.
NEARLY 30,000 UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN WERE ENCOUNTERED.
SOME 3,000 OF THEM 12 YEARS OLD
OR YOUNGER.
ARRESTS AND DEPORTATIONS
PLUNGED AS PRESIDENT BIDEN
TIGHTENED THE RULES HOW ICE
AGENTS CAN OPERATE.
THERE WERE MORE THAN 2300
ARRESTS IN FEBRUARY.
THAT’S DOWN 66% FROM THE
AVERAGE NUMBER OVER OCTOBER,
NOVEMBER, ON DECEMBER.
AND ONLY ABOUT HALF THE NUMBER
OF DEPORTATIONS IF  IN FEBRUARY
COMPARED TO THE MONTH BEFORE.
FEWER PEOPLE STOPPED AT THE
BORDER OR ELSEWHERE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
REPUBLICANS FROM BORDER STATES
ARE GOING AFTER THE BIDEN WHITE
HOUSE OVER THIS.
>> CARTELS HAVE OPERATIONAL
CONTROL OF OUR BORDER.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION KNOWS
IT AND THEY DON’T CARE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO
ABOUT THIS CATASTROPHE?
IT IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
>> STOP SPENDING YOUR TIME COW
TO YOUING TO THE RADICAL LEFT.
STEP UP AND HELP US FIX IT.
>> YOU WOULD HAVE TO HAVE THE
MOST ACUTE CASE OF SUSPENDED
REALITY TO DENY THAT WE HAVE A
BORDER CRISIS.
>> Harris: KEN CUCCINELLI
FORMER ACTING DHS SECRETARY A
KEY PLAYER IN PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
BORDER SECURITY TRAGEDY IS WITH
ME NOW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
SO THIS IS UNFOLDING NOW BEFORE
OUR EYES IN A MUCH MORE RAPID
PACE.
AND I HEAR DEMOCRATS SAYING
THIS HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
WHY DIDN’T IT HAPPEN LAST YEAR?
WHAT REALLY SPECIFICALLY IS
BEING DRIVEN BY BIDEN POLICY?
>> IT DOES NOT HAPPEN ALL TIME.
THAT’S THE LUDICROUS STATEMENT.
PART OF THE REASON THEY’RE
TRYING SO DESPERATELY TO PLAY
THIS DOWN AND AVOID USING THE
WORD CRISIS IS THAT JOE BIDEN
IS PERSONALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THIS.
HE IS PERSONALLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS.
HE INVITED THEM TO COME
ILLEGALLY.
WHAT YOU JUST HEARD JACOBSON
CALL A MORE HUMANE POLICY.
WHAT THEY MEAN IS WE WON’T
ENFORCE THE LAW.
THAT’S WHAT THEY MEAN.
THEY HAVE BROADCAST THAT ACROSS
THE WORLD AND THE WORLD IS
RESPONDING, JUST AS THEY
EXPECTED IT TO.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, THEY ARE
STOPPING DEPORTATIONS.
SO ANYBODY WHO COMES ILLEGALLY
KNOWS THEY WON’T BE SENT HOME.
AND THEY ARE REENACTING CATCH
AND RELEASE.
IT IS REALLY JUST A HELLO, MR.
BORDER PATROL AGENT, NICE TO
SEE YOU.
I’LL JUST MOVE ON TO CHICAGO,
TO NEW YORK, TO VIRGINIA, TO
IOWA, WHATEVER.
AND FRANKLY THEY ARE TURNING
THEIR TRANSPORTATION RESOURCES
NOT TO RETURNING DEPORTING
PEOPLE BUT TO MOVING THEM
FARTHER INTO OUR OWN COUNTRY.
SO THIS IS -- THEY BROUGHT THIS
ON THEMSELVES AND THEY’RE
FACILITATING IT.
>> Harris: WE’VE SEEN BUS
COMPANIES WHO HAVE SEEN PEOPLE
RESPONSIBLE FOR TRANSPORT
SAYING WE NEED NEGATIVE
COVID-19 TESTS WHEN THE PEOPLE
GET ON BUSES.
THAT’S THE ADULTS.
THE SITUATION WITH THE
CHILDREN, THAT’S ON OUR SOUL.
OVER THE LAST 21 DAYS CBP
REPORTEDLY ENCOUNTERED 435
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
UP FROM THE PREVIOUS AVERAGE OF
ABOUT 340.
THEY ARE STAYING IN FACILITIES
FOR 107 HOURS ON AVERAGE,
LONGER THAN THE 72 PERMITTED
UNDER U.S. LAW.
A WEEK AGO, KEN, THE AVERAGE
TIME WAS 77 HOURS.
WE’RE GOING FASH  -- FAR NORTH
OF THAT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING?
>> YOU CAN EXPECT THE NUMBER TO
KEEP GOING ON.
WE WERE DOWN AROUND 24 HOURS
WHEN WE GOT OUR ARMS AROUND THE
LAST CRISIS IN MAY OF 2019.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO WRONG WAY.
THEY ARE GOING THE OTHER WAY
AND IT WAS AMAZING TO WATCH JEN
PSAKI SAY WE DON’T HAVE THE
FACILITIES TO HOLD THESE KIDS
BUT IT IS NOT A CRISIS ALL IN
THE SAME BREATH.
THEY CAN’T DO CATCH AND RELEASE
WITH CHILDREN.
IT’S THE ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE,
THE UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN, YOU
CAN’T JUST TURN OUT ONTO THE
SIDEWALK.
IN YOUR INTRODUCTORY REPORT IS
UNDER 12 YEARS OLD.
FAMILIES GO TO THE BORDER.
SHOVE THEIR KIDS ACROSS.
IT WOULD BE TALKED ABOUT AS
CHILD NEGLECT AND HERE OUR
GOVERNMENT IS THE NEXT CHAIN IN
THE HUMAN SMUGGLING OPERATION.
>> Harris: WE FIND OUT THEY
HAVE THESE COLORED BRACE LETS.
HUMAN SMUGGLERS ARE USING A
SYSTEM OF COLORED WRIST BAND TO
INFORMATION ON THE WRIST BANDS
USED FOR SMUGGLING
ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY NOTE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WERE PAID FOR COMING ACROSS.
AN ADULT ON THE SOUTHERN PART
OF THE BORDER HAD TO PAY OR
WHAT AFFILIATION WITH SMUGGLING
GROUPS THEY MIGHT BE.
THIS IS SO DANGEROUS FOR THE
KIDS.
ONE LAST WORD ON THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
CHIP ROY TALKED ABOUT THIS.
YOU HAVE MEXICAN OFFICIALS
SPEAKING ANONYMOUSLY ABOUT HOW
DANGEROUS THIS IS AND WE’RE
GOING TO SEE AGAIN IT IS GOING
ON, WE’RE JUST NOT TESTING FOR
IT, THE RECYCLING OF CHILDREN
ACROSS THAT BORDER BY THE
CARTELS.
THIS IS A BONANZA FOR THE MOST
VICIOUS, EVIL ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE, THE
MEXICAN DRUG CARTELS WHO DO
CONTROL THAT BORDER.
>> Harris: THE TECHNOLOGY I WAS
JUST TALKING ABOUT, OF COURSE,
THAT’S THE INCENTIVE THAT
MEXICO SAYS THAT IT IS WORRIED
ABOUT NOW.
JUST TALK TO US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW DIFFERENT THE
RELATIONSHIP IS ALREADY WITH
OUR SOUTHERN NEIGHBOR?
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD
GOTTEN TO A PLACE WHERE IF YOU
ARE SEEKING ASYLUM YOU STAY
THERE SOUTH OF OUR BORDER IN
MEXICO.
NOW MEXICO IS SAYING WOW, THIS
IS BECOMING A BIG BUSINESS IN
THEIR COUNTRY TO SMUGGLE
ESPECIALLY WITH THOSE WRIST
BANDS.
THEY CAN TELL WHO HAS PAID AND
WHO HASN’T.
>> IT’S A FULL INTELLIGENCE
NETWORK AND THE CARTELS ENACTED
NEW BUSINESS PROCEDURES BECAUSE
THAT’S HOW THEY VIEW IT.
WHEN JOE BIDEN WAS SWORN IN
BECAUSE THEY COULD GET AWAY
WITH IT.
THEY KNEW IT BECAUSE JOE BIDEN
TOLD THEM THAT.
PUBLICLY.
YOU CAN LOOK ALL THE WAY BACK
FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS.
THIS HAS BEEN COMING AND IN
FACT THEY WERE GEARING UP
BEFORE HE WAS SWORN IN.
MEXICO’S PRESIDENT SAID THIS IS
UNSUSTAINABLE AS REUTERS
REPORTED.
THIS IS NOT DOING ANYTHING
POSITIVE FOR OUR NEIGHBORS TO
THE SOUTH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT THROUGH
SORT OF TOUGH NEGOTIATING BUT
GOT TO SOME VERY STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS, STRONG
COOPERATION, THE BEST WE’VE
EVER HAD WITH THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES OF
GUATEMALA, HONDURAS AND EL
SALVADOR AND MEXICO.
YOU DESCRIBE THE ROLE MEXICO
PLAYED VERY ACCURATELY.
IT WAS CRITICAL.
WHEN MIGRANTS KNEW IF THEY CAME
UP HERE ILLEGALLY THEY WOULD
HAVE TO STAY IN MEXICO, IT
DAMPENED THEIR INTEREST TO
COMING UP.
IT WAS THE TRUMP EFFECT.
WE’RE NOW SEEING THE BIDEN
EFFECT.
WHAT AN INVITATION TO A WHOLE
BUNCH OF ILLEGALS WILL DO IS
FLOOD A BORDER AND THAT’S WHAT
IS HAPPENING AND IT WILL
CONTINUE TO GET WORSE.
THIS IS EARLY IN THE SEASON,
HARRIS.
NORMALLY THE PEAK OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION COMES MUCH LATER IN
THE YEAR.
>> Harris: WHEN IT STARTS TO
REALLY GET WARM.
WE DO KNOW THAT.
IT MUST BE FRUSTRATING FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WORKED SO HARD
ON THIS TO WATCH IT BEING
UNRAVELED AND SOME ARE SAYING
THEY ARE COMING BECAUSE OF THE
POLICIES, THEY FEEL LIKE THEY